[Música]
hablemos de las noticias de la salud
Buen día para usted Omar más Romero sala
con noticias el día de hoy bien
interesantes como está Buenos días
Ángeles Así es un estudio sobre la
genética de los primates tiene
resultados que son reveladores para
nosotros los humanos Sí y de hecho los
humanos somos primates también solo que
este estudio se centra en todos esos
primates que no son humanos un equipo de
científicos se propuso Investigar la
genética de estos animales para
comprender mejor nuestro propio árbol
evolutivo los resultados se publicaron
en un grupo de cinco estudios en Science
y uno del derecho de los de las
instituciones coautoras y líderes de
esta investigación es de Barcelona que
por supuesto lo voy a destacar porque es
mi ciudad natal se trata de un esfuerzo
nunca antes visto en este campo implicó
un centenar de científicos de 20 países
distintos que lograron secuenciar la
genética el ADN de 800 primates de más
de 200 especies distintas desde los que
son los más grandes por ejemplo hasta
los lemures que son algunos de los más
pequeños Entonces qué es especialmente
interesante también antes de entrar en
detalle sobre los resultados de esta
investigación Y es que para por ejemplo
uno de los estudios de las variantes
genéticas y de las diferencias genéticas
dentro de las propias especies de
animales y para comprar estas especies
con la humana se utilizó un algoritmo de
Inteligencia artificial que ya es
nuestra vieja amiga de la que Hablamos
casi que cada día aquí el algoritmo este
de aprendizaje de Inteligencia
artificial encontró 4,3 millones de
variantes genéticas que va a servir para
recoger muchísima información por
ejemplo para predecir si estas variables
si estas variantes son benignas o son
potencialmente peligrosas Cuáles son los
hallazgos que se han encontrado gracias
a este algoritmo es realmente uno de los
procesos más interesantes de este
estudio que comprende varias disciplinas
y que también responde a varias
preguntas pero en este caso lo que
hicieron fue secuenciar como decía todo
el ADN de estas de estos ejemplares de
especies de los primates no humanos y
los introdujeron a este algoritmo con
esta información digamos lo que hicieron
fue entrenar esta este algoritmo de
Inteligencia artificial de aprendizaje
para identificar qué mutaciones están
asociadas a enfermedades Y luego con la
Inteligencia artificial y el algoritmo
ya ha entrenado lo que hicieron No fue
revisar un registro de datos biomédicos
de casi medio millón de personas que se
han recogido gracias a la información
del biobanco de Reino Unido donadas por
voluntarios Y eso dibuja un mapa de
variantes genéticas que sirve para
muchísimas cosas por ejemplo dentro de
la confusión de qué mutaciones o qué
variantes pueden ser potencialmente
peligrosas sirve para descartar no si
una mutación encontrada de pronto en una
persona que sufre una enfermedad se
consideraba que era sospechosa pero se
encuentra muy ampliamente en los
primates nos sirve para inferir que
probablemente sea benigna y que no Esa
es la causante o está relacionada con la
enfermedad y no nos debería preocupar
Pero entre las que sí nos deberían
preocupar precisamente está este 73% más
de vínculos que se han encontrado entre
las variantes genéticas y las
enfermedades hablamos de enfermedades
como cáncer diabetes enfermedades de
corazón que tienen unos orígenes
múltiples no no solo la genética influye
que por lo tanto Eso hace que sea
especialmente difícil saber qué piezas
del puzzle genético encajan ahí y que
gracias a todo este torrente de
información que se ha recogido nuevo
Pues podría arrojar más luz sobre Estos
tipos de información esta investigación
mar también ayuda a comprender mejor
nuestra propia evolución sí como
decíamos gracias a secuenciar estos ADN
de tantos animales que son muy parecidos
a nosotros podemos entender Qué
características o entender mejor al
menos son únicamente exclusivamente
humanas y cuáles no de hecho lo que
encontraron fueron 89 variantes en 80
genes distintos que son exclusivos de
los humanos es decir que nos definen un
poco como especie y esto de hecho se
reduce reduce a la mitad las variantes
que creíamos que nos hacían únicamente
humanos de alguna forma nos acercan
todavía más al resto de los animales que
siguen siendo primates pero que no son
humanos recordemos aquí que nosotros
tenemos unos 100.000 genes por lo tanto
un centenar de diferencia no es mucho y
pues refuerza no en la hipótesis o la
teoría que está sobre la que trabajan
estos científicos más que la hipótesis
la certeza de hecho de que tiene mucho
sentido estudiar a los primates para al
resto de primates para comprender mejor
cómo funcionamos como humanos por último
también arroja luces de estudio sobre
los procesos de extinción de algunos de
estos animales Sí sacándonos un poco del
Spotlight del centro de atención a los
humanos también es muy importante la
información que se ha recogido sobre los
propios animales y también sobre la bio
del planeta que habitamos algunas de las
especies que se estudiaron están en
peligro de extinción o han visto su
población reducida drásticamente en los
últimos años y en las revistas hayan
recuerdan que normalmente el desplome de
la población de una especie también
estrecha su diversidad genética por
culpa de la endogamia entre los mismos
supervivientes sin embargo excepto 15 de
las de las 200 especies que se
estudiaron todas mostraron una
diversidad genética muy alta más alta
incluso que la de los humanos eso
sugiere Entonces que la caída de la
población a causa de la destrucción del
hábitat ha sido tan rápida que no ha
habido tiempo de que la genética de
estos animales refleje Esta caída de
población todavía y esto en realidad es
una muy buena noticia No de hecho nos
muestra de que puede ser incluso
reversible que haya diversidad genética
entre una población de animales que se
creía que estaba en las últimas Es una
muy buena noticia porque nos muestra que
no está todo perdido nos enseña también
Qué podemos hacer para conseguir
recuperar la biodiversidad de estos
animales y comprender mejor pues cómo
los podemos ayudar a sobrevivir pues más
no sé si usted va a estar de acuerdo
conmigo precisamente usted que trae
temas a veces tan complejos al estudio
de France 24 en que nuestra labor aquí
como periodistas eso mostraré una
información que puede ser muy valiosa
para nuestros televidentes pero yo sí
los invitaría a que se tomaran el tiempo
para leer de manera más reflexiva y más
amplia porque pues en cinco minutos no
alcanzamos a abordar todas las aristas
que tienen este estudio grueso de una
investigación Así es pero los invito a
que revisen la página web porque hay más
explicaciones ahí sobre este tema
Muchísimas gracias a ti Ángela